let's talk about cancel culture
understand
that we have um relatively
um unforged uh we are in relatively
unforged territory
uh in the united states with the current
american right wing the american right
wing
is out of ideas the american right can't
win on policy
their health care ideas aren't popular
their economic ideas aren't popular
their social ideas are out of the 19th
century
they're totally wrong in every way on
covid
they don't accept science even on
increasingly uncontroversial topics
they can't win met when more people vote
so the right tries to suppress the vote
trump in combination with the republican
right
lost the house in 2018 lost the senate
in 2020
lost the white house in 2020 not by a
little bit
by a lot as trump likes to say these
people's ideas
while clinging to support in the united
states are the laughingstock of the
world
so as we've talked about before they
make themselves
victims to justify their own existence
and because they have nothing else left
and their latest path
in so doing is talking about so-called
cancel culture and so their entire cpac
conservative political action conference
that we saw over the weekend
was crafted around this idea
the slogan was america uncanceled
trump talked about cancel culture many
of the speakers did
now i've said this before but it bears
repeating once again
cancel culture as described by the right
does not exist it's the latest ploy
met to rile people up just like
pretending
trans women in sports is the major issue
facing the united states of america
i'm not saying it's not an issue
it's just not a major issue that relates
to the lives of 99 percent of the
country
now let me be very careful i whenever i
do this i have to issue a disclaimer
to try to save my inbox and it still
won't work but it'll help
if you were going to argue that i'm
wrong by emailing me
an article about one person that was
unfairly fired for a political view they
tweeted about
or an article about someone who was
fired because their political opinion
clashed with that of others in their
workplace or something like that
that doesn't disprove what i'm saying in
this segment
i will gladly admit that sometimes there
are
unfair firings just like sometimes there
are
false rape reports this is a country of
more than 330 million people
there are examples of everything but
basing an ideology
around something insanely rare
pretending that a main policy issue
is something that statistically is
barely there is a ploy
weaponized by the right to attack the
left
to attack organizations to attack
institutions to attack
social media platforms when the right
doesn't like the decisions that they
make
cancel culture is the perfect ruse for
so many right-wing goals
right-wing politicians need to portray
themselves as victims
claiming that social media networks and
journalists in academia are
all out to get them is the perfect way
to do it
religious right folks need to claim
that their religion is under attack that
jesus primarily
is under attack this is the perfect way
to do it
right-wing politicians need to raise
money we know
that socio-cultural issues real or
imagined
doesn't matter if they exist or not are
great for fundraising
right-wing media needs to make money
outrage porn
about cancellations of republican
politicians or of right-wing media
itself or of potato head or dr
seuss or whatever it is perfect fodder
for
ratings and importantly the right is
generally less divided on cultural
issues this goes back a long time
on economic issues you see more of a
range of views among the right in part
because of the libertarian right
in many studies including a good one
from vanderbilt university
republican positions on cultural issues
exist within a much tighter range
than they do among the left so they can
easily generate
more unity and more outrage among the
right
with these cultural issues against a
shared enemy
this is truly the perfect ruse and it's
working
now in reality what they mean by cancel
culture
is that sometimes their speech has
consequences
and it essentially describes free market
capitalism which they claim to support
and you know what that's the way things
work free speech
the first amendment usually the first
amendment doesn't even apply but they
talk about it
none of that comes with immunity from
the consequences of your speech that's
one of the elements of capitalism
that's one of the elements of markets
your speech enters
a marketplace of ideas and sometimes
there are consequences
except in very narrowly defined
situations
the consequences to your speech are
someone else's free speech which must
also be protected
what the right wants is carte blanche
to continue their policies of economic
discrimination
elitism xenophobia homophobia christian
supremacy
white supremacy whatever whatever it is
they prioritize
they want to perpetuate that and
insulate themselves
by using the term cancel culture to
intimidate the left into not criticizing
them
to intimidate the market into not having
consequences
for their speech let's not fall for it
now
give me a specific example of something
that was done wrong i will look at it
if someone didn't deserve to be fired i
will look at it and i'll tell you they
didn't deserve to be fired
but this is the way that the right is
organizing its followers
against real progressive change and
to justify their own existence absent
any
substantive policy ideas going on five
years now
the trump era was devoid of actual
policy completely
and it is now essentially a grievance
movement
and so often you know we talk about
projection from the right
there are these um enclaves of the right
that love to say the left is now just a
grievance movement
when i look at the left sure there's
some grievance in some circles but the
predominant
left-wing movement uh is around economic
equality accepting science and acting on
it when it comes to covid
when it comes to climate when it comes
to so many different things it's about a
15 minimum wage
it's about getting health care to people
it's there's policy there right now for
the most part and
yes on the fringes you have the the sort
of grievance-focused elements
which i have no problem criticizing and
have done for years it is actually the
right
via this cancel culture meme that has
become uniquely
about victims self-victimization and
grievances now
next i want to look at some hilarious
examples of how the right is now going
absolutely
crazy with the cancel culture story
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
cal tech scientists with only one
mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen cinnamon and
pomegranate they also have lozenges
which come in cherry
ice flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's time to throw the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of
excellent reviews online from countless
people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give these products contain nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical